David Crosby teacher children was
recorded when teach your children was
you're asking me hard stuff right away
teacher children was recorded in about
1969 1970 I think at 69 where'd you get
the idea for the song
um it's Nash's song and he got the idea
for it from something quite natural that
that all of us have which is so wanting
to pass along you know truth to our kids
not lie to them and the hope you know
that if we give them good information
they may do a better job than we did I
think it's one of the best of the Crosby
Stills Nash & Young songs that ever came
out you know I wish I had been the
author but I'm proud to sing it you talk
about that and a lot of other songs in
concert concerts in the book stand and
be counted why did you write the book I
wrote the book for several reasons one
um because we found David bender my
co-author and I found that no one else
had written anything about it uh I have
always been um you know sort of an
activist at least since quite a ways
back there and not and I've always been
fascinated with you know human courage
with people having the guts to stick up
for what they believe it and when it
occurred to me to maybe try to write
something about you know benefits peace
marches civil rights demonstrations and
the use of music as a focal point for
those I said David you know um has
anybody written anything about this and
he came back he said no that's it come
on
he said no there isn't anything not a
word so we looked at it and I you know
here's the two major you know phenomena
of the last fifty years in the United
States are probably that in some
people's view anyway the civil rights
movement and the Vietnam War
well the civil rights movement was
activism entirely that's what fueled it
that's that's what Martin Luther King
was you know and the Vietnam War was
strongly affected by activism and nobody
had looked at it from the point of view
of how does music affect you know how
was music used you know to gather people
in these causes and we started looking
at it further and it just fascinated us
so we couldn't help right it was the
first time he ever did a concert for a
benefit that had something to do with
politics politics or something
effectively yeah so yeah you know
politics is a different issue we have to
we have to get into that one that's
where it really gets tricky the first
time that I remember doing a benefit I
was I think the first one might have
been one that Nash and I did for Jane
Fonda for a thing called the Winter
Soldier investigation which was fueling
the exposure of the melee massacre ah it
was either that one or one that we did
in San Francisco where we split the
proceeds between a whale saving
organization and the United Farm Workers
over the years what have you felt the
strongest about when it comes to issues
I feel pretty strongly about all of the
ones that I get involved in I think it
was I think we were all very passionate
about the war the war in Vietnam was
such a divisive issue the country was so
polarized you either were really really
strongly against it or you were you know
Richard Nixon and we I think probably
that that was the strongest fuel
although after Kent State you know it
was pretty hard not to have that be
paramount you know in our minds when a
country starts shooting its own children
you know that something is not right
I love even playing music you know um
since I was about six what year was that
right after the Civil War but 1947 how
accurate how accurate you are sir yes
about that why did you get into music my
parents played music my mom sang in
choirs my father played the mandolin my
brother played guitar we used to sing
folk songs around the fire at night you
know we were just a musical family where
did you go up I grew up in Los Angeles
up until about fifth grade and then went
to moved to Santa Barbara which is a
wonderful place and I still live near
there what did your parents do my father
was a cinematographer that's a cameraman
in film he won one of the first Academy
Awards they ever gave out for a film
called taboo you ever see High Noon my
father shot hiding it it's a very very
good cinematographer but your mom my mom
was a mom
she came from the days when moms were
moms and that was all moms got to do and
she was a very sweet lady very artistic
I think she could have been a good poet
or a good painter either one did you go
to college
um one year but they threw me out um I I
have to confess that I was thrown out of
almost every school I was over in do you
know why oh oh yes I I know why question
is will I tell you my I I was somewhat
of a disciplinary problem I think they
used to say I was a disruptive influence
do you know why you were a disciplinary
problem or did it come from
I think I didn't deal well with
Authority uh of course now that I'm
growing up it's completely different no
not really
that character still is there on page 67
in your book there's a couple paragraphs
taking a minute or so to read it it it
seemed to touch on a lot of different
things including your home life if you
don't mind I'll read it and then ask you
break it down for us you say at the risk
of calling into question my own current
choice of staying straight I still
believe we were right about acid and we
were right about pot they did blow us
loose from the past and they did give us
a new perspective a way of setting
ourselves apart from the rest of
straight society there's a kind of
knowledge that acid gives you on a
cellular level about what's really going
on with birth and growth and death and
everything else like it or not it's true
that psychedelics are away not the only
way but clearly an effective way of
gaining tremendous insight into life the
government lied to us about so many
things that we just assumed that
everything it said was a lie quote if
you take that asset you'll stare at the
Sun and burn out your eyes unquote you
say wrong quote if you take that acid
you'll have bad babies unquote you say
wrong quote if you take that acid you'll
immediately think you can
fly and jump off a building you say it
wrong so when they said that marijuana
was a gateway drug and would lead to
harder drugs we just went right just
like all the other stuff you told us
that wasn't true that's definitely me
what's all that about I think you know
it speaks for itself I uh you know I I
you know of course as you well know got
involved with much harder drugs and they
had to make a choice to not do anything
in order to get away from those drugs I
found out that I was one of those people
who sort of built with no brakes and I
so it doesn't serve me well to to do
anything I don't even drink a beer but I
have found that in in ignorance and in
an overzealous attempt you know to be
anti-drug that people in the straight
world particularly governmental sorts
tend to lump it all together drugs bad
good way well drugs are all different
they're all completely different their
effect is different their source is
different their level of involvement in
your life is different I have said this
many times and I will say it again even
though I personally make the choice to
not do anything if my child came to me
and said you know dad I'm going to go
out and buy a quart of Jack Daniels or a
quarter pound of pot what should I do
that's it hang on I'll get you the pot
mom because I think booze is far more
damaging to you you know so I think you
know judge you're a complex issue you
know and I I personally think that that
the best way to go about it is to not
have to do any at all to just tune
yourself to the kind of consciousness
you want and stay there which you can do
doesn't have any side effects and you
don't have to pay for it
I like that way but I don't approve of a
lot of the way it's being dealt with in
this country you know not that it does
much to do with this book or activism
but no I don't I don't approve of how
it's being dealt with I think
overzealous people you know I put in
mandatory sentencing laws that take the
the that make it so a judge can't be a
judge I their sentencing people you know
to ten years for two joints down in
Texas still and that's the joke - Joe
you know it's a bad joke I don't know
you know win it and if will be able to
you know straighten it out and get sane
laws you know that separate out the
various issues you know obviously I
think you should come down on coke and
heroin as hard as you can but then I
think you should come down on drunk
drivers as hard as you can't do it so
you know it's a complex issue when did
you stop 1985 December 10th what was the
reason they put me in prison for what
dope and a gun in Texas and how did they
what were the circumstances I got busted
we playing music at the time yeah I got
busted repeatedly up and you know one
time I finally got busted and it wasn't
- you know something I could get out of
and I went up doing a year in in prison
again not that it has much to do with
this book but it was it served me well
in terms of you know experience what did
you do during that year I read a great
deal um and I had the time to you know
figure out who I was again what did you
find
found somebody I liked that I had lost
and what do you like about what you
found they'll give us well you know I
found a guy that it's actually a pretty
happy guy
that's pretty creative and has a lot of
fun with life and can move forward and
learn new things and grow and change and
accomplish things I'd pretty much lost
track of that go back to the other part
of this where you talk about the
government line where did you first feel
the government lied to you um I think
government and lying is sort of just
synonymous almost I don't think they
mean to be but the first case in my life
where I knew the government had lied was
I remembered back back when when Radio
Free Europe used to say throw off your
communist masters and we will come to
your aid and Budapest did and we sat
there and twiddle our thumbs and said oh
my oh heavens oh dear when they sent in
the tanks and crushed Budapest and I
said but wait a minute we lied to these
people we told them we were going to
save them if they that was the first
time there were many other you have a
chapter on political activism in which
you talk and by the way how did you and
David bender do this together who is he
by the way David bender has been my dear
friend for many many many years and he
is one of the brightest human beings I
know and he's an accomplished writer and
has been my political mentor for many
years he has worked in in politics on a
number of different levels you know
aiding a number of people and he knows
more about it than I do by a very great
deal and so when I try to figure out why
something happened or how something
happened or who voted which way he's the
guy that I
and we became very close friends and
he's somebody that I enjoy riding up
with I'm pretty sure we will write a
number of books so how did you do the
book together what was the what were the
circumstances I thought so much um he
did all the research uh we would do
interview sessions where you know he
would tape me then we would get those
transcribed then we would find the
cogent or lucid parts of those tapes and
we would take them and uh match them
with sections that he would write you
know and intersperse them you know so
that it became a you know a single voice
as nearly as we could do it you know and
I think we succeeded let me read some of
what you're saying in the book they'll
tell you whatever you want to hear to
get your help for whatever project is at
hand
which is usually getting themselves
re-elected they want money for their
campaigns and they want your standing
next to them if you're big enough I've
done it only rarely it's a very dicey
proposition a few candidates Ted Kennedy
is one who comes to mind immediately
have stood up for principle at least the
principles that matter to me and I have
regret never regretted supporting
someone like that others like Bill
Clinton talk a pretty good game but when
push comes to shove they find some way
to wiggle out of the commitments they've
made that's here explain more of this
have you been asked often by politicians
to do centers get asked all the time
there's a thing that you may not know
which is that when an entertainer does a
benefit concert for a politician each
ticket is an individual contribution
that's probably what you call a loophole
because it means that we can give more
than most people can so we get
approached a great deal we get
approached also for our visibility you
know my opinion of politicians you know
varies from day to day you know and it
depends on which one I'm talking about
to because uh there are you know like
any group of people they have all kinds
there are guys in there that I think we
should run out of town on a rail you
know and there are people who are pretty
much you know of good conscience but
caught up in a bad system I am I feel
very strongly about campaign finance
reform because I think that the way it
works right now you know a senator has
to spend more than half his time you
know out whoring himself out to get
money and of course there are all those
guys in the $2,000 suits just standing
around dying to stuff it in his pockets
you know from the corporations because
they want to buy a senator they want to
buy a congressman they they want that
contract and that takes our
representative democracy out of your
hands in my hand means it
disenfranchises us and I don't feel that
that's the way it's supposed to work the
guy with the most TV money isn't isn't
supposed to automatically get the
election the people who framed the
Constitution did so in in the Gutenberg
Age and they did not envision the power
of television the power of mass media
and until we correct for that until we
make it so that there is a system and
I'm not smart enough to design the
system I don't know what it is but until
we can make a system that makes it so
you can't just get 100
by promising all kinds of unscrupulous
behavior and take that in our million
dollars over here and by TV time and win
the presidency like that um
this systems out of whack I mean that's
what's going on right now that's what's
going on right now in this election
right now both sides you know a plague
on both their houses they're both doing
it and I I know that's not how it's
supposed to work and I think most of the
people in the United States know that's
not how it's supposed to work everyone
that I've ever talked to about it so
it's not why should I vote you know for
chrissakes Aryan they're just buying it
with you know throwing million dollar
bills Adam what what can my what the
hell good is my vote going to do well
that vote is the key
the single vote of the informed
electorate in its mass and it's in its
totality is how this government is
supposed to work and it isn't working
that way and until we fix it we got a
mess as we take this interview you are
coming off of a 34 city tour seems like
about a hundred and thirty-four but yeah
something like that
when did it start she's right after the
Civil War a long time ago I don't
remember like the first a year yeah
something like that and who what group
is that what as you went around who was
diverted who was the group karlie still
describes me cells nationally on which
is why it was so big as neil was
involved how was the tour unbelievable
very intense very artistically
satisfying as much fun as I could
possibly have was it was a delight when
did you come together first as Crosby
Stills and Nash 67 something like that
how long were you together
we've always been together the only year
that we didn't play it was the year I
was in prison when did Jung join you the
second record
daijobu better Becky joined right after
we made the first record how many years
of those have you played together I mean
it's done concerts every one of those
years since Pete Olson - yes Crosby
Stills Nash and young know Neil's you
know went off on his own a long time ago
in as a huge star and having him with us
was very exciting because he's a very
exciting musician how many albums have
you made don't know many many if a
favorite album a favorite song that you
get asked about all the time asking the
guy what his favorite song is the sort
of like saying what's your favorite
child you know it's a very tough to pick
one let me ask you the other side of
that question one that you always ask I
mean you say oh here we go again
too many we we have dozens you know of
songs that that were the soundtrack to
people's lives that I think that's why
they caught the tour it was so strong
you know ohayo what did you order right
that Neil wrote it in a place called
butanol Canyon and the circumstances
were that somebody brought that magazine
with a picture of the girl kneeling over
the kid dead on the ground and he looked
at the picture and thought for a little
while and then he wrote that song and we
went immediately into the studio and
recorded it and we felt so strongly
about it that we we put it out right
away as a matter of fact Nash did an
incredible thing we had teacher children
going up the charts like a rocket as a
hit and Nash took it off the market so
that eight miles I mean so that so that
Ohio could go on in its place
because we thought it was that important
it's part of the function of a you know
of who we are is to be troubadours to I
think and that was us doing that how
much do you think what you did over the
years Vietnam war all the other issues
you've been involved in have had a
direct effect well I don't know what I
did at the group music and concerts and
you know the matter how much the group
did I know how much the overall effect
of all of the people trying to affect
things had there isn't any question but
what we affected the Vietnam War we made
people you know choose we made people
look we made people investigate we made
people question and I and that affected
the course of the war there isn't any
question about it even the government
admits that it infected the course of
the war in the case of civil rights
movement or the environmental movement
or the act
you know the any number of other
movements you know with we've had a
definite effect things don't change as
fast as we would like them to because
societies have inertia
there is societal inertia and uh we
thought we could stop that war in a year
and it took us ten uh you know but at a
certain point some farmer in Iowa said I
don't think this is right I don't think
I want my boy to go that was the day we
won Crosby Stills Nash and young any of
you who serve in the military uh no did
you ever have a year faced with a draft
yes I was what happened I told him I was
a commie pinko bed-wetter murderer
rapist uh you know Firebug everything
else I can think of did it work yeah did
you really tell him that you were no III
had already been a convicted felon and
and that's probably what got me I mean
back in the 60s yeah what was that fell
on me that one was for burglary naughty
boy
childhood prank page 13 of your book you
say I think he scared them you're
talking about JFK this is right after
the assassination we think he scared
them
I think the establishment was terrified
it was going to cave in and give the
country away to the [ __ ] and [ __ ]
is in italics don't like the word
however it's it's sort of a quote I've
heard people say that these were bigots
and bad guys but they weren't stupid
they saw what King was doing and that
Kennedy was basically on his side and
both of them were dead within five years
accident you say question mark crazy
lone government question mark yeah right
where were they dead question mark
because they were dangerous to the power
structure of the country King in
particular King pattered himself after
Gandhi a single man who not violently
ended British rule in India King and
Kennedy were dangerous men because they
believed what we believed that you could
stand on principle and effect change for
the better
they weren't Saints we know that now and
it doesn't matter what matters is that
they were right I think that's all true
and I think um see the thing about
Kennedy was that the normal procedure as
we've already discussed here is that a
man running for president goes out and
makes deals to get money because if you
give me you know ten million bucks I
guarantee you you that that b-2 bomber
will be built in your town and that's
how they get the money well Jack Kennedy
didn't have to do that you had the money
uncle George already made almond food
like and he had plenty of money that
made him a very dangerous man he did not
have to make the normal sorts of deals
that every other president has had to
make and that gave him an independence
and then he got his brother in there an
Attorney General and it was starting to
look pretty dynastic and pretty tough he
was starting to mess with things that
were established patterns in this
country established power bases and he
didn't have to go to them hat in hand so
I think they did view him as a very
dangerous man
you've screamed out at a concert or to
the Warren Report is a lie I firmly
believe the Warren Report was a lie
don't you what happened what happened mm
good question I believe some some very
wonderful people Dalton Trumbo directed
it and Robert Ryan and will Gere acted
in and then if I got out of their
deathbeds would cancer to act in it
there was a movie called executive
action and I believe it told pretty much
an accurate story of what happened he
was a you know a hit and it certainly
wasn't a lone gunman you know if you
watch the Zapruder film the guy got hit
from two directions there's no question
about it also I've been there and stood
in Dealey Plaza behind the fence and I
go to hit him with a handgun it's not
very far how did you get interested in
Tibet the same way most people do man
that's beautiful it's one of the oldest
most beautiful cultures on earth one of
the world's great religions Tibetan
Buddhism and I think you know I feel the
way a lot of people do that that we're
watching it be stamped out by you know
the
people who are running China
successfully stamped out of existing you
say in the book you're married to Jan a
Buddhist oh yeah she does practice
Buddhism yet is it all tight as it's all
tied together your interest in that and
no i-i've always left a bit what does it
mean to be a Buddhist I'm not qualified
answer me but go back to the Tibet I
mean - that has a about six million
people I think it's two men inside and
six four five nine around the on the
edges and it's inside China why is it
you choose Tibet say over Rwanda I
didn't choose it uh and it's inside
China because China took it it was its
own country a beautiful country of its
own with its own culture and its own
religion and it doesn't deserve to
simply be absorbed by the Chinese
because they're big nor do we nor should
we allow them you know favored nation
trading status and everything else just
for you know big bucks and say oh it's
okay if you trample your own people and
steal a country or - it's alright wait
just buy enough of these TVs and
everything's fine I don't approve of
that and I don't have to I'm not gonna
think it stinks I was at a rally on the
Capitol Steps about it and some
aggressive woman reporter came up to me
and said what do you think you're doing
here you're not going to get China outta
to bat get real I said you know you're
probably right I said but I am NOT able
to sit idly by and and just let it
happen any more than I would have sat
idly by in 1939 and said ah they're just
Jews it's not my style
how do you decide what concerts you'll
be involved in for what causes it's very
difficult you have to you have to
priorities prioritize we get asked
people who are known to do benefits get
asked you know to do a hundred a year
easily and you sort of wind up picking
areas you know that particularly you
know appeal to you things that are of
particular concern to you I like to do
stuff that involves that that affects
kids I put on a benefit every year where
I live to try and put music into the
public school system but you know I do a
lot I do I've done a number of things
for voters for choice
I do ones that affect the environment I
do I do
you know most areas that the one where
I'm most careful is politics you know in
for reasons that we've discussed one of
the things that you talked about in the
book is a motor voter did you all have
something to do with that it's something
that we strongly approve of you know
registering people to vote any way you
can do it I don't care if they do it at
McDonald's if you can get people
registered to vote do it you know we
need this country is based upon and it
says in the papers there and informed
electorate that are willing to be
involved that are willing to go out and
vote
that requires a that they be registered
B that they be informed and see that
they believe in the system right now
they don't believe in the system what's
your reaction to the fact that the
reports on motor voter after it was
passed is that they're registered more
Republicans than they did Democrat I
don't care are you a member of a party
not really I'm a constitutionalist I
strongly strongly believe in the
Constitution the Bill of Rights and the
Declaration of Independence I'm I have
voted Democratic more than I voted
Republican let's put it that way
but I I'm deeply disturbed by stuff that
I see going on in both parties also
involved in rock the boat started 1990s
a yeah we think that's a good one
it was quoting you to fight right-wing
attempts to censor music don't like
fight don't like right-wing attempts
they don't like any wing attempts to
censor music or anything else but we do
like rock the book because Rock the Vote
tends to get younger people involved you
know the younger voter getting involved
in the system lends it credibility in a
way that we need very badly how many
children do you well um three that that
I am raising and two that another family
or reason explained it I don't think
that's really what we came to talk about
but it's in the book I mean you write
about your son in the book that you
hadn't seen for a lot of years well I
have a son Django my youngest who is the
light of my life
I have a daughter dahlias your young son
he's for Nia I have a daughter Donovan
Ann who is 23 who is an animator and
illustrator brilliant very proud
I have a son James Raymond who was given
up for adoption by his mom at birth whom
I only came in contact with about four
years ago five years ago who without
knowing that I was his father became a
musician he's a brilliant musician he's
better musician than I am and he and I
have a band called CPR that's a great
deal of joy to me and then I am the
genetic father of both of Melissa
Etheridge and Julie ciphers kids
but I'm not their parent I'm simply the
genetic donor and very proud of it
they're very great kids and they have a
great family now back to Raymond what do
you tell someone like Raymond or even
your younger kids about all the things
you've learned through life that it's in
this book all these different
experiences do you try to give them
advice about politics about drugs about
my grown children have very strong
opinions about it of their own and don't
need much you know in in terms of me
telling them you know what I think they
pretty much know what I think I'm a
fairly outspoken person what I'm going
to tell Django as he grows up you know
I'd rather show him than tell him I'd
rather that he watched how I live my
life and what choices I make and that he
you know either emulate those or not as
he sees fit yet a river liver transplant
I did when November 18th 1994 and what
was the reason
hepatitis C it's a an amazing plague
upon the land now there's I think well
the National Institute of Health came
out and said they thought there were
probably 2.7 million cases inside the
United States the World Health
Organization puts it closer to 5 million
cases inside the United States probably
80% of whom don't know they have it and
they're merrily passing it along how do
you get it blood transfer primarily but
it got all through the blood supply and
all through the population before we
realized that it existed and you know
blood transfer could just be you know
the same toothbrush
doesn't take a lot of blood i-it in the
rest of the world they think there's
probably a hundred and twenty million
cases almost all of whom don't know they
have it and only in Western Europe and
North America can they even test for it
and they have no treatment for it
whatsoever you know really that is a
fact I mean that's not sure they have
treatments for it but they are effective
only in a small percentage of the cases
maybe thirty how long did you have to
wait I had to wait a long time I was 71
days in the hospital and I came within
days of dying before we got a match up
how you doing now
I am very healthy a couple of things in
the book I want to ask you about you you
mentioned a number of performers like
Jimi Hendrix and Janis Joplin and Phil
Ochs and others that in the middle of
their performances were the drunker high
on drugs or whatever and it just as I
kept reading I kept asking if you're
having such a good time at this business
why were people using so much substance
when they're getting on that I I really
don't know why we felt that that we
should or could you know but we did it
was just how you did things and I wish
the heck we hadn't I personally myself I
know I can do a better job when I'm
straight I can remember the words better
I and I'm much more focused and I'm much
more in tune with the audience if I'm
not stoned the other thing you reveal is
the temperament of some of your fellow
musicians I mean the stories like
remembering one where Madonna was coming
into some event and her bodyguards I
can't remember the person forced some
well-known entertainer to look the other
way when she walked by do you remember
the story yeah who was it yeah it was a
friend of mine getting Mike Hulbert mom
was told to avert his eyes um
which I think may well have just been
you know an excess of zeal on the part
of the security people but if it came
from the star in question it certainly
shows something about how they feel
about themselves and you quote in here
Bob Dylan at one point somebody's
talking to in the middle of a concert
saying I hope we can play blowing in the
wind and get the heck out of here and he
looks very temperamental throughout the
whole book what's the story Bob isn't it
known but temperamental is too light a
word to describe Bob Bob is extremely
complex and and he's also very much his
own man and he makes his own decisions
about what he wants to do and when he
wants to do it he's not easily
manipulatable that was an aside that he
made to Joan Baez that he didn't know
anybody heard but the microphone was on
we got the tape are you at all worried
about some of these stories that they're
being told for the first time I heard no
not really
it's not a tell-all kind of book you
know what it is many more than anything
else is it's a primer a way to get a
glimpse at the idea that you can make a
difference that one person can stick up
for what they believe in and make a
difference and it shows you how various
people have done that it traces also
this this line that we see anyway from
you know Thoreau to Gandhi to King to us
you know there's a line there there's a
connection there you know and I and even
when the connection isn't there this
seems to occur quite naturally in people
of good conscience there seems to be an
ethic that spontaneously combusts in
people where they say gee you know
that's not right I can't just sit here
and watch this go on and not say
something or they say gee you know I
could make that better I could help here
I think I will and what we found is that
that's the case and we're very happy
with it when we see that in human beings
it's it elevates human beings I think
one of the things we found is that not
only does you know being an activist and
doing benefits and doing you know good
work healthy and whatever you're trying
to help but it helps you it elevates
your life it without question has you
know helped my life and every single
person that I've talked to about it says
that it has elevated theirs that it's
quite possibly their favorite part of
the whole thing tell us a little bit
about each of your fellow band members
Stephen Stills what's he like fiery
strong bright immensely creative
stubborn good man you're 58 how old is
he a year younger Graham Nash a
gentleman a man who came out of one of
the toughest industrial cities in Europe
and educated himself made himself read
himself learned himself into being a
world-class authority on art a collector
of art whose collection tourist museums
brilliant photographer a mensch one of
the nicest men I've ever met you all
think alike not at all on politics not
even in politics no we're not we're not
similar people I think that's one of the
reasons that the chemistry works as well
as it does Neil Young Canadian brilliant
are very very much of an individual I've
never met anybody like him focused
tremendously focused human being has it
worked out very clearly what's important
to him and what's not spends his time
only on that which is
say he has two kids with cerebral palsy
he has two kids
I don't think both of them have cerebral
palsy has one k2s cerebral palsy very
seriously yes and you do concerts called
at the bridge school concert what is
that the bridge school is a wonderful
school that that Neal and Peggy mostly
Peggy young have started to aid kids who
are unable to communicate with their
with their own voice to enable them to
communicate with the world there are
great many kids who have CP or other
kinds of nerve you know impairment who
are still home in there there in there
you know and they have tried to find a
way to bridge that gap hence bridge to
through these or computers through other
kinds of ways to to allow these kids to
communicate with their outside world and
it's a very brave effort one that we
support very strongly
what's the Seva foundation say the
foundation is a wonderful group of
people who try to do good all over the
world they became famous for a mobile
eye clinic that went into areas of the
world like Nepal and Bhutan and and
Tibet and northern India and saved
people's sight who otherwise simply
would have gone blind from things that
in this country nobody would be blind
from you know glaucoma and stuff that we
can operate on here nothing no problem
there no surgeon no lab so they flew one
in when you do these concerts and you
talk about a lot of the money that's
being raised how do you assure yourself
that somebody's not ripping people off
we do the homework in what way well uh
we either run it ourselves
which I do in the in the case of the one
that I do every year in say in setting
is where I live or we get somebody ah
that we trust there's a guy that many of
us use named Tom Campbell
he runs an outfit called guacamole Tom's
pretty amazing individual he is
currently out there
planning the Earth Day celebration
tomorrow where I'm going to play and he
has done stuff from as few as 50 people
up to the Meuse concerts where we filled
Battery Park with a quarter of a million
people after doing five nights at
Madison Square Garden he's very honest
man six pretty much of a curmudgeon but
definitely an honest man he's neither
one that through Paul Simon off the
stage ones might be you tell that in the
book might be what happened I don't know
I wasn't watching yeah but you say in
the book that you that's never been told
before I don't think it has been I don't
think he knew it was fall he don't think
for this day he knew it was Paul Simon I
think he found out later you know why
did he throw him off the stage I
probably didn't have a path we tend to
do that you know if you think you're
very recognizable you don't wear your
pass you know you assume that your face
is your path I do that all the time why
is it so many and you did I'm taking it
from your book so many stars are so
temperamental kind of or temperamental I
think it's more complex than that where
we're you know we tend to be strongly
opinionated we tend to be intelligent we
tend to be fiercely emotional and that
could be read as temperamental but I
don't think it's as as lightweight as
temperamental I don't think it's just a
fit of pique and oh I can't stand the
soup just throw it away
I think it's that we're strongly
emotional people we feel things very
strongly and and I think
you know people see that their way
there's another reference in here and
correct me if I'm wrong there's a
Whitney Houston story about was that her
bodyguards moving Whoopi Goldberg out of
the way someplace in where these
concerts yeah a dumb move
why Whoopi's were the smartest toughest
best people on earth you don't want to
don't want to be on web spin side John
Mellencamp is quoted in here as saying I
don't want any part of any of this stuff
John's a very independent guy a
good-hearted guy even though he says he
doesn't want to do part of any of this
stuff he does Farm Aid every year
because he you know farm AIDS a very
clean machine there are there are
benefit organizations man very well
known ones will pick United crusade
simply because it's their that take you
know sixty percent of the money for
administration then there are places
like Farm Aid that kick 83 80 to 83
percent of the money out the door farm a
it's a clean machine farm it has the
support of every everybody that I know
of in the entire entertainment industry
any of us would do at any time what was
the fundraiser that took 11 years to get
the money to UNICEF that was Bangladesh
when did that happen that happened early
on I'm not sure the exact year but but
the problem was lawyers lawyers
Shakespeare was right about the lawyers
you raised 13 million dollars well I
didn't but it did you know and it took
11 years to get that money free like I
said Shakespeare was right about the
lawyers
how many concerts are here do you do now
it varies from year to year but probably
20 you know sometimes 10 sometimes more
you know I do as many as I can fit into
my life having nearly died I've realized
you know that I have a very limited span
here and that time is the final currency
not money not power it's time and so I
try to use every second of my time as
wisely as I can and that means been that
means spending a great deal of it with
my kids and and my wife and but I you
know I believe in trying to you know do
good where II where you can I think it's
a good thing to do
looking back after all the experience
you've had what do you think of the
country this country this country I
think it's the finest defence of
personal freedom that exists on the face
of the planet certainly the best country
there is what would you change right now
if you if you could I would change the
political system in so much as I would
unquestionably change as I said campaign
finance reform the elections are not
supposed to be for sale it's that simple
that's not how it's supposed to work
short of that I think the country is
working pretty well we're doing you know
we're certainly lots of things are still
wrong you know here but we're working on
now you also indicate in the book that
you've done a documentary we did a
documentary as we were doing this book
when I went to Whoopi was one of the
people that I asked as a friend you know
to participate she said sure what you
have to bring a camera and I said why
she said because it's supposed to be a
documentary fool and I said oh and I was
taking a little aback because of my
father made documentaries and I know how
hard it is to make a documentary
documentaries are very tough to get the
money for it nothing blows up
no car chases nobody takes their clothes
off so it's very tough ah but we did a
very kind very good man named norm
weight gave us you know her to heard
about the project and gave us the money
to make the documentary and the
documentary is going to be on The
Learning Channel on August 22nd 23rd two
hours a night for two nights
and how much of what you have in the
book is in the documentary way more what
do you think of all this experience of
doing a book
I thought the experience of doing this
one was was wonderful it made me look at
something that I have always loved I am
always as I said at the beginning of
this conversation
loved the courage you know for people to
stand up for what they believe in doing
the book let me take a closer look at
that we're going to close with another
one of your tunes Judy blue eyes when'd
you do this first that was one of the
first songs we recorded like 1967 what's
the story behind it well still says it's
about him falling in love with a very
beautiful blue-eyed girl named Judy
who's Judy Collins who wrote the song
Steve itself our guest David Crosby with
David bender for this book stand and be
counted
thank you thank you